sur le terrain la ligne de front elle
est figée depuis l'échec de la
contreoffensive lancée au début de l'été
l'an dernier les précisions de notre
correspondant Guliver Krag dans la
région de
Kramatorsk je vous parle depuis
droukivka une ville située à une
trentaine de kilomètres seulement de
bakmou et donc de la ligne de front
cette ville avait 5000 habitants avant
l'invasion à grande échelle et en compte
aujourd'hui environ 40000 parce que ce
qui était parti au début de la Grande
Guerre en grande partie sont revenus
faut d'avoir trouvé des emplois ou des
logements convenable ailleurs et puis
aussi parce que des gens sont venus
notamment de bakmou qui a été détruit et
occupé par les forces russes ou bien
d'autres villes plus près de la ligne de
front ou qui sont considéré comme plus
dangereux trou kivka jusqu'à présent a
été relativement épargné par les frappes
russes même si la ville est hautement
militarisée comme vous voyez peut-être
derrière moi il y a beaucoup de soldats
en ville ce matin nous avons parlé à
certains d'entre eux l'un d'entre eux
m'a dit tout simplement quand je lui ai
demandé comment ça allait et bien ça
pourrait aller bien mieux d'autres ont
admis qu'ils étaient fatigués qu'ils
avaient besoin de relèves mais ils ont
dit qu'ils tiennent la ligne sous une
pression russe qui s'est augmenté ces
dernières semaines les Russes sont
passés à l'attaque sur toute la ligne de
front dans l'Est mais les soldats
Ukrainiens disent pour le moment euh
réussir à tenir leur position sans subir
de pertes territo Royal majeur mais
quand on leur demande s'ils sont
confiants qu'ils peuvent continuer comme
ça ils répondent non tout dépendra de
l'aide occidentale et donc les annonces
comme cell faites hier en France de la
création d'une coalition pour
l'artillerie pour fournir plus notamment
de AER français à l'Ukraine et des
munitions sont absolument les bienvenus
mais toujours on nous répond la même
chose presque cela devait arriver déjà
hier nous avons aussi posé la question
aux soldats à qui nous avons on parlait
ici ce matin des mercenaires français
que la Russie prétend avoir tué à
harkive une information que la France
démment ils nous ont répondu qu'ils n'en
savaient rien mais que en tout cas ils
ne parle jamais de mercenaires quand il
s'agit des étrangers qui viennent
combattre au côté des Ukrainiens pour
eux ce sont des volontaires il convient
peut-être de rajouter que la Russie
souvent dit avoir tué des mercenaires ou
des agents étrangers quand ils ont
bombardé tel ou tel a
c'est une information qui à ma
connaissance n'a jamais été confirmée